I didn't get it because I was thinking
you know if someone can change their
gender which for many women can be very
offensive you know why can't I say I'm
Korean I'm not hurting anyone I've got
to a point now where I realized that
wasn't making me happy it wasn't
addiction I've thankfully beat that
addiction I think you're actually
incredibly brave because you did all
this in public and then within a very
short period of time said actually you
know this this is wrong interestingly
enough in Korea and China a lot of
people had surgery to emulate Caucasian
features so a higher nose Bridge double
eyelid surgery so I don't understand why
people you know have an issue with me
having these surgeries to look Korean
when everyone in Korea is trying to look
you know westernized when you just give
a kid a phone and they have unlimited
access to the internet what are they
seeing on Tick Tock and if they're
seeing that from age three until they're
a teenager you know that's 10 years of
indoctrination we should support all
people but you know kids shouldn't be
you know forced or pressurized to do
this from kindergarten Garden I wanted
to cut it off completely to transition
to become a woman and is that one of the
points where you went uh okay maybe this
is starting to get yeah I was thinking
you know that's something I could could
regret yeah
I might miss that one there's a balance
that needs to be struck between the
rights of the individual and also as
well realizing that this is a mental
illness absolutely
thank you are you tired of using bulky
old wallets giving you a bulge where you
don't want it to be my old wallet was
massive so it brought all the ladies to
the yard which was a huge distraction
and got in the way of my esteemed work
on trigonometry reg wallets have an
incredible solution for you this is mine
Sleek stylish and with an industrial
look to it can fit 12 cards with cash on
the back using a clip like this one or a
strap we've got one for the whole team
I've got one Francis has one even our
producer Anton has one but he's from
Liverpool so he flogged his on the black
market the great thing about Ridge is
that they give you a lifetime guarantee
which means if you want you can have
only one wallet for the rest of your
life Rich are so confident in the
quality of their product they will give
you 45 days to test drive their wallets
that means you can get the wallet use it
and if you don't like it you can return
it within 45 days because Ridge is such
great guys they're gonna give three
worldwide shipping and returns to take
advantage of this incredible offer go to
ridge.com forward slash trigger
hello and welcome to trigonometry I'm
Francis Foster I'm Constantine kitten
and this is a show for you if you want
honest conversations with Fascinating
People Our Guest today is an online
personality who's best known for
transitioning to being Korean and then
most recently de-transitioning back
Ollie London welcome to trigonometry
thanks very much it's a real pleasure to
be here with you guys uh people who
won't know your story will might be
quite shocked by what I just said it
sounds a bit crazy it does sound a
little crazy so before we get into the
conversation itself for anyone who
doesn't know who you are didn't Follow
Your Story who are you how are you where
you are what has been the journey
through life that leads you to be
sitting here talking to us by the way
our first in-person recording in the
studio so welcome wow I feel so blessed
to be the first person in beautiful
Studio by the way guys
um so I'm Ollie London and for those of
um for those people out there that don't
know me I'm a social media personality I
do Instagram Tick Tock YouTube I also
I'm a K-pop singer so I released my own
Korean pop music some of it's in English
some of them Korean and a lot of people
know me for my extreme obsession with
career which I've kind of got over now
I've kind of moved on from that but I
was very obsessed with career I used to
live in South Korea for a year and I
became infatuated with a specific KPop
star called jimin and I modeled myself
on him so I started having surgery to
look like him and then I got to a point
where I was you know kind of getting
addicted to the surgery and I thought
maybe I can be Korean I love Korea why
not everyone else can make their own
pronouns and genders and identities
these days so why not and obviously I
got some hate for that and you know I've
kind of grown from that and trying to
learn and you know now I'm trying to
just be myself yeah well
it's a little bit more complicated than
that isn't it because uh I mean you
spent a [ __ ] ton of money uh and a lot
you had like there's surgeries that I
could probably need to do that aren't
cosmetic right that I'm like you know
what I'll do that when I really you know
what I mean most people avoid having
surgery you had a lot of them in a short
period of time you spent According to
some people like a quarter of a million
dollars doing it and
also as you say you pissed off a lot of
people particularly Korean people who
were like well you can't just transition
to being Korean you know you can't just
like be another ethnicity nationality so
why did you want to be Korean or this
particular person did you want to be
Korean or did you want to be like this
guy what was that it started out I was
living in Korea for a year and then
slowly over time I just became really in
love with Korean culture and I felt
really happy for the first time in my
life when I lived that I felt like I
belonged somewhere I felt like I fitted
in and you know Korean people accepted
me and I wanted to be a part of that and
it's actually not very unusual what I
did because uh foreigners that live in
Korea they all get the surgery they all
change their hair they start speaking
Korean they start acting Korean everyone
does it in Korea it's just like an
addiction K-pop is such an incredible
phenomenon and if anyone that's lived in
Korea they fall for this and you know
they want to be Korean they might not
say it publicly like me but they all
feel that way they all try to identify
that way
um and they even become Korean citizens
as well so you know the Koreans actually
didn't really get pissed off at me did
they not they were actually even to this
day they're very grateful that I'm
always promoting their culture sometimes
they think okay he's a bit wacky but you
know he's fun he's entertaining people
he's spreading K-pop um but really it
was kind of more of the woke culture
that took offense to me you know oh did
they but you know I find that weird
because they're the same people that
preach about acceptance about you know
not judging people about anyone can
identify however they feel inside and
you know I generally had an affinity
with Korea and I was like why not you
know everyone else can identify some
people actually identify as clowns and
they use clown pronouns and it's like
yeah it's true it's true what a clown
pronouns
I guess
pronouns that I use are they them she
her and clown clown self this is Cyprus
and Cloud mentioned not having people
use clown or clown self pronouns for
clown and so in this situation I would
make sure that I exclusively use clone
pronouns to talk about Cyprus so Cyprus
knows that I see clown self for who
clown is and I want clown to be hearing
those pronouns more than the other ones
out of my mouth so like I thought if
someone can identify as a clown you know
why can't I identify as Korean what's
the harm in that right and of course you
know it had a backlash and you know I
didn't get it at the time now I kind of
understand it more but I didn't get it
because I was thinking you know if
someone can change their gender which
for many women can be very offensive you
know why can't I say I'm Korean I'm not
hurting anyone I'm doing something that
makes me happy and I'm showing my love
for a particular culture what was it
about career that made you fall in love
with their culture well there's so many
aspects um if you're in Korea it's the
music it's the Korean dramas it's the
people it's just the whole culture as a
whole the history it's a beautiful
um country rich in kind of history and
um it's just an incredible place so
there's so many aspects um but yeah
really the people I fell in love with
the way they looked but also the way
they behaved and the way they act the
very kind and sweet um and yeah I did
for you know I was always unhappy with
my looks I thought I want to look a
different way why can't I look Korean
why can't I like a pop star like jimin
to feel happier inside and I've got to a
point now where I realized that wasn't
making me happy so now I'm just trying
to be myself and you know I'm the
happiest I've ever been what why were
you unhappy with your look solid um so
when I was a teen at school I was
bullied like all the time every day like
some days I wouldn't go to school I
would try and make myself sick so I
didn't have to go to school but my mum
would still make me go to school
um and when she was doing the right
thing she didn't realize I was getting
bullied um but yeah I used to get
bullied do you know people would say I
had a really big nose I used to have
very bad acne and very bad skin so that
really led me to have severe
self-confidence issues um you know
self-esteem issues and I just felt
really bad about myself so when I had an
opportunity in Korea to have surgery you
know there are surgeries literally
everywhere
um I was like you know maybe I can
actually be happy maybe I can look good
you know maybe people can look at me and
think oh he looks handsome or he looks
nice so you you had so so how did it
start because is it right to almost
frame this as an addiction to plastic
surgery that you had you know I will
admit it it's an it was an addiction yes
I'll admit it now and thankfully I'm
pretty much over that addiction I'm not
considering any more surgeries I'm kind
of just trying to be content with who I
am and there's a lot of surgeries I
regret you know I don't have much
movement in my face I actually have
metal in my face in my chin my chin was
broken and my cheeks are there's things
that I regret and you know I can't take
back the past it was an addiction I've
thankfully beat that addiction
um but you know is there any Wonder
people get these addictions with things
like social media that you know kind of
feed this we have the Kardashians we
have K-pop stars and you know they all
have surgery they don't like to admit it
they all have surgery 90 of K-pop stars
do and you know it's it's become a norms
so is there any Wonder people fall for
this addiction yeah well you know it it
I should say a couple of things first uh
the first thing I I should say is that I
think you're actually incredibly brave
because you did all this in public and
then within a very short period of time
said actually you know this this is
wrong and you're now speaking out about
transitioning and all of this other
stuff that we're going to talk about so
um while you know I'll be honest with
you five months or six months or
whatever it was ago when you the story
first came up in the news you know
Francis and I do this satirical comedy
show three nights a week called raw and
this guy from like London decided to be
Korean right we were taking the piss
because it's kind of it's a crazy story
of course right but I I actually think
that you know you should know that when
Francis and I are asking you about this
I think your story is probably
wackier than most in terms of the type
of transition that you went through but
it's actually quite emblematic I think
of of what a lot of people are
potentially being exposed to because you
talk about being bullied you know when I
was a teenager there were kids around me
who would have been bullied every day
and didn't want to go to school but none
of them none of them decided at that
time that they needed to transition and
be something else because it just wasn't
available and you mentioned social media
where did you get the idea that the
answer to your problems would be to
change yourself physically well it
firstly started in Korea you are
inundated with Billboards absolutely
everywhere when there's more plastic
surgeries than there are supermarkets in
Korea it's literally insane The District
in Gangnam which is kind of the plastic
surgery capital of the world there's
probably about
um a thousand um clinics within a square
mile that's how crazy it is so it's
basically it was kind of put in your
face everywhere you can look perfect you
can look beautiful and everyone in Korea
was doing it and I had that self-esteem
issue I was so unhappy and I thought
maybe I can be happy as well maybe I can
look like that billboard maybe I can
look like that advertisement and you
know we see that a lot across Asia you
know plastic surgery is a booming
business and interestingly enough in
Korea and China a lot of people have
surgery to emulate Caucasian features so
a higher nose Bridge double eyelid
surgery so what I was doing was
obviously different and it only started
as a nose surgery I just wanted to fix
my nose and then it kind of became an
addiction but you know what I've been
doing is kind of the reverse of what's
been going on in Asia so I don't
understand why people you know have an
issue with me having these surgeries to
look Korean when everyone in Korea is
trying to look you know westernized
that's that's such a good point because
obviously they do do that what the thing
that I worry about maybe I'm getting old
now but I just think
yeah that is she still look great thank
you ollie
um but where should YouTube care for the
surgeons and their clients how do they
discern that this is an operation that
is needed and is merited and how do they
discern that you know that this this
person is ill maybe they have body
dysmorphia maybe you were not doing the
right thing by your patient so a
credible
um doctor would actually have a
psychologist on hand so with a with a
good doctor you would have a psychology
appointment before the surgery a
consultation which will be about an hour
long and it would go really in depth to
your family history any issues with like
substance abuse any issues with body
dysmorphia so you go through all that
not every doctor has that though it
depends what country you know I've had
surgery I think about six or seven
countries I can't even remember so I
kind of go around the world because you
know the UK the doctors are quite strict
and they weren't really telling me what
I wanted to hear so I was going to
foreign countries so what were they
telling you what does that mean a lot of
them were saying no like
um some doctors wouldn't perform a nose
surgery on me because I'd already had my
nose done and they didn't want to do
revisions they said that's too risky or
some of them were just too conservative
and you know I wanted kind of an unusual
look and they wouldn't give that so you
know I found a way to find somewhere
that would do it you know I was going
all over the world
um and you know I think young people if
they really want to do something they do
find a way and you know I have found in
the past doctors via Instagram you know
one of the docs I nearly died like I had
a gynecomastia which was removing all
the fat from my chest and uh basically I
was in agony I couldn't move for days
and days and days and I had these tubes
inside my body to drain the blood and
without water I didn't even know they
were there to be honest without warning
he ripped them out one day I had no
morphine and stuff I was literally an
Agony I was like shaking so much um and
that was in Armenia so you know I'd gone
to that country because I couldn't find
a doctor here that would do what I
wanted so I think that's the risk young
people will find a way to get these
surgeries and there's not always checks
and balances so I would say from
experience you know for young people
they're really really sure about
something think about it for a few years
you know for a girl wants to get breasts
as a woman or someone wants to change a
nose if it's really been on their mind
go to a good doctor you know don't kind
of skip things and go to like a doctor
that will just say yes to everything
because that's where things can go wrong
and so moving through you've had these
different surgeries uh to make you look
uh more Korean
and then when do you go you know what
I'm not sure I should have done this
when does how does that happen well
actually it kind of developed because I
got to a point I had more surgery last
year I had
um so many surgeries I think I went
under knife three times last year
um I had the eye surgery and that's when
I said you know I feel Korean why not if
everyone else can identify different
ways um and then earlier this year I
actually underwent 11 surgeries in one
day and you know I'm very happy with the
results now it made my face at the time
more feminine and you know I was unhappy
still and I thought maybe I'm trapped in
the wrong body and it sounds crazy but
you know I became trans for a while
because my whole life you know I was
always a bit more feminine I didn't fit
in and I generally thought you know if
Society is saying oh it's normal to
transition and stuff I kind of fell for
that and I was like okay maybe I'm meant
to be a woman may I stop you there sorry
you say Society is saying it's normal to
transition
how how did you get that impression
because we all live in our own bubbles
now don't we like the the bubble that I
live in I don't think that is the common
the common thread you know what I mean
so so when you say society says it's
normal to transition what do you mean so
basically if you go online on any social
media platform or indeed in the school
system in America
um kids are being taught from a young
age they're transitioning you know you
can do it as a kid
um obviously I'm an adult so I
transitioned as an adult but you know
when you've got everyone around the
world Educators people on social media
celebrities you know normalizing this
and saying it's easy as one two three no
I thought it was an easy thing and I had
the facial feminization I was actually
going to go do body surgery as well
thankfully I didn't you know but when
you have that constantly pushed
particularly online I spent all my time
online so much on social media and stuff
and you know it's so easy it's so normal
you know maybe so that's what you're
being told you're being told having
surgery is easy it's normal it's and
also transitioning you know if you're if
you're feeling lost if you're feeling
confused with your gender it's because
you are trans is because you're trapped
in the wrong body so I thought that I
was trapped in the wrong body so I
thought you know maybe the Korean thing
is not not right it's maybe it's
actually the fact I'm in the wrong
gender so I transitioned I had facial
feminization I had I mean my forehead
bones that shaved down my eyebrow bone
shaved down had another eye surgery chin
uh cheek fat removed here like did so
many things and you know I love the
results now because it looks nicer than
I was but um at the same time I just
feel like
um I could have done more to myself I
was going to go to Thailand and do body
surgery I could have died and I would
have also been left with deep regret for
the rest of my life so no I just think
my message is you know not to stop
people doing these things people want to
do it if that's what they really believe
do it but just just you know educate
yourself on the risks and also don't
rush into things you know don't do
something because it's trending all
because people on social media are
saying do this it's easy you know for
kids in America when they're being told
um by influencers or schools that you
know at age 12 take puberty blockers we
can give you a double mastectomy when
it's it's comes across as it's easy and
they don't realizing it is a lifelong
consequence these kids will be on
medication for their whole life there's
a lot of Health implications there's not
enough research so that's the reason you
know I'm trying to share to try and help
people I'm an adult but people so people
are being children are being misinformed
so come back to the story because I
interrupted you I just felt that that
was an important point of pleasure yeah
yeah but you you have all these
surgeries and you thought you were trans
for a while after thinking you're and
when do you go actually you know what
maybe I'm I'm neither maybe I'm just
well it was again it was about four
months ago so I got to a point where I
was still unhappy I was thinking okay I
became Korean I became trans I've had
all this surgery now I'm thinking about
doing more surgery irreversible surgery
that I really can't change is this what
I want you know I look in the mirror
every day and I'd have the surgery and
for two months I would be so happy it's
weird because when I have a swollen face
I actually feel beautiful sounds weird
but that was when I feel my most
beautiful and then after that wears off
I kind of feel like oh I look too normal
um so it got to a stage where I'm
thinking okay am I crazy like have I got
body dysmorphia why am I doing this you
know I was losing relationships with
friends family you know everyone was
moving away from me because they were so
upset with what I was doing and
obviously people online
um were upset with me and stuff and I'm
thinking what am I doing to myself so
um I actually was lost and I was
thinking I need direction in my life so
I thought let me just go to church I
hadn't been to church in years I used to
go as a kid I was actually raised
atheist but I used to go as a kid um at
a church of England school and I just
went into church just like let me just
have some peace let me sit calmly at the
back and think and reflect on my life
and that was a defining moment for me it
was like
um you know stop what you're doing just
be happy with who you are and then I
started going to church more started
reading the Bible just the teachings
um of Jesus and I realized you know it's
like just be you know be the way you're
born you know stop doing all this crazy
thing because at the end of the day it's
not fulfilling me it's not giving me
happiness it's harming me it's harming
other people you know what's the point
of all this it doesn't even matter what
I look like it's what's inside that
counts and that's when I also had an
Awakening is like you know I actually
regretted what I was doing online on
Tick Tock and stuff because maybe I was
persuading people to have surgeries or
maybe I was persuading people to become
Korean or whatever and I felt you know
actually I have a moral responsibility
with you know I've got two million
followers online I have a responsibility
for these kids these people that look up
to me I need to send them a good message
you know so that's why I've kind of been
trying to do some activism to try and
spread love and positivity in the world
and just to try and you know spread a
better message rather than you know
getting surgery is cool being Korean is
cool you know it's I just felt bad for
what I was doing
hey Francis if you were a member of the
public would you like the opportunity to
ask incredible guests like Bill Burr
Jordan Peterson Sam Harris Adam Carolla
Brett Weinstein John Barnes Douglas
Murray Nigel farage and Lionel Shriver
your own questions you bet I would and
what do you think the best way to do
that would be uh probably stalking mate
you'd have to Corner them in the
supermarket probably around near like
the sort of frozen food of and then just
bought questions at them before they can
escape not the American ones as they
have guns and you'd have to be extra
careful with the females as that's how I
got in trouble last time do you really
imagine you're gonna get Douglas Murray
near the frozen food aisle if you want
to ask our incredible guest questions
and have access to phenomenal behind the
scenes content then you have to be on
our locals that's right for only seven
dollars a month you get incredible extra
content behind the scenes footage
giveaways and also the chance to be part
of an incredible Community where you can
meet and hang out with like-minded
people you get access to our American
Vlogs as we travel across the country
interviewing Our Heroes an extra 20
minutes of our viral Sam Harris episode
as he discusses his approach to covert
we're also going to start doing
giveaways of exclusive trigonometry
merchandise like this a poster from our
Edinburgh show signed by both of us and
also a House of Lords Teddy which you
can only get in the House of Lords
signed by the one and only baroness Fox
locals also gives you access to an
incredible online community you can
share memes talk about the latest
episode or even make a new friend or
just one exactly more than both of us
have really people are now doing meetups
in their City because they love locals
in fact some people enjoy it so much
they prefer it over the show they prefer
locals to trigonometry
if I have to get them executed I'm the
one that goes to jail right go to
trigonometry.locals.com only seven
dollars a month for all that incredible
content
trigonometry.locals.com See you there
guys
did nobody at any point sit you down and
go Ollie I really think you need to talk
to somebody yeah a lot of times like my
family friends
um I stopped talking to a lot of my
family uh for you know multiple times
for like weeks the time after surgeries
and I would never inform people I was
having a surgery I would just go and do
it and post it online or you know
whatever and because I thought you know
I don't want to message individual
people and say oh by the way I've just
had another surgery you know I'll just
put it online my family will have to
deal with it that way and that was
actually very irresponsible of me that
was wrong of me I put people through a
lot of pain and suffering and you know a
lot of people tried to stop me but you
know I'm a very headstrong person I
don't really listen I should listen to
people you know I should start I'm
trying to to grow as a person I should
start listening to people and taking
people's advice um but at the time it
was like I was so headstrong I was
hell-bent on I want to look a certain
way I wouldn't look like a K-pop Star
and then I was thinking okay I want to
be trans and it's you know I'm a bit
crazy but like I go through trends like
I go through phases and you know young
people are going few phases now where
they have gender dysphoria and they're
very confused and you know as a teen
it's a very confusing time you you do
question yourself and that's a very
normal thing but we shouldn't have as a
society be telling kids you know go
transition go get a surgery when they're
a kid you know I believe if people want
to transition do it as an adult
absolutely I support all people but I
just don't think we should be pushing A
Narrative on kids and minors when it's
not healthy you know they may have
gender dysphoria we need to give them
love and comfort and support but we
shouldn't be encouraging you know
um doing things to themselves do you
think that you had gender dysphoria
Ollie when you were thinking about
transitioning yeah obviously I'm not a
kid I was when I transitioned fully it
was actually earlier this year so I was
32 so I definitely have gender dysphoria
and probably an identity crisis of some
sort because I've had quite a few
different identities so yeah I
definitely think gender dysphoria and
just um very low self-esteem embody
dysmorphia and um it's become
increasingly common
um to have these things in in the US
medically diagnosed as around 270 000
teens that are medically diagnosed with
gender dysphoria
um in terms of uh kids identifying as
trans or non-binary that has doubled uh
since 2016 according to
um research from the Williams Institute
at the UCLA so it's like it's uh there's
studies being done on this so there's
basically a real increase in the last
couple of years in people identifying in
different ways people with body
dysmorphia and uh social media obviously
has a huge impact you know we see
everyone uses a filter we look up to
people like Kim Kardashian you know and
you know some people love her some
people hate her but at the end of the
day so many people look up to her she's
got over 300 million followers she has a
lot of surgery you know is she sending
the right message to kids you know
that's up to them to decide but um I
feel with the uh kind of social media's
rise like Tick Tock and stuff people are
developing these um you know gender
dysphorias and bodied small fear based
on this it's weird because you said well
I'm a little crazy but you know we've
spent some time with you before they
into it I I think some of the stuff
you've done is crazy I I agree but but I
don't get the sense that you're crazy at
all you seem actually like a pretty uh
grounded sensible normal person to me
which I think is kind of part of why to
a lot of people this is such a concern
because someone who Okay low self-esteem
okay you had a bad bad experiences at
school you didn't enjoy going to school
a lot of children throughout the entire
history of the human race will have
experienced both of those as teenagers
and I'm going into adulthood and
sometimes you know sometimes it takes an
entire life to work out who who are you
what are you supposed to be doing with
your life what is your purpose what is
the job that you want to do that's all
part of the human development but now we
have such powerful technology both in
terms of the surgeries but also in terms
of the social media the spreading of the
message that that if there's something
wrong with if you feel something is
slightly not quite right with you she is
a you know a whole range of options for
you you can do this you can do this and
I think that's where a lot of people's
concerns comes in because it's almost
like you give your child a phone you
have no idea what what's going to end up
happening exactly I mean your point is
like thousands of years you know it's
normal for a teen or kid to question
themselves to question their identity to
feel you know left out to want to fit
into the society so uh you know if
people watching this um when they're a
teen you do try to fit into the with the
cool kids in school right so if the
current cool kids are trans or
non-binary you also want to be like them
because you want to be part of that
social group so it's a kind of there's a
lot of psychology psychological elements
to it but again with kids having access
to phones from a very young age I mean
you know kids four or five they have
phones they have Tick Tock which is very
risky because you know the parents can't
monitor them all day it's not healthy
for their development it's better for
them to be reading books doing sports
you know doing art going to museums you
know that's more healthy that's what I
grew up with and I'm sure most of us
grew up with um when you just give a kid
a phone and they have unlimited access
to the internet what are they seeing on
Tick Tock and if they're seeing that
from age three until they're a teenager
you know that's 10 years of
indoctrination they are going to believe
that and that's also a risk with things
like Tick Tock is um you know the
algorithm it's obviously Tick Tock is
owned by a Chinese company and there are
risks with that as well because the
algorithms promote certain views you
know politically culturally socially and
over time this can shape children's
opinions on things so you know if you're
getting constantly on an algorithm
someone that is telling kids to
transition like Dylan mulvani the
influencer you know kids are going to
want to do that because it's trending
they constantly see it it's normalized
for them so I think that's the risk of
technology and I think kids I'm sorry
parents should pay better attention to
what their kids are doing and maybe no
limit their access you know let them go
on YouTube let them watch you know
cartoons or videos or whatever
exactly but you know so just be careful
you know I don't think a kid should have
Tick Tock or Instagram you know I mean
of course with teens they all want to do
it all their friends have it it's kind
of hard for parents to stop them but
when you're a kid you shouldn't really
be using those platforms because there's
a lot of harm online I completely agree
with you which are the worst uh
platforms for this because I can't
imagine too many kids are on Facebook
Facebook seems like an older person's
thing Twitter I again not really is it
primarily Tick Tock and Instagram yeah I
mean Twitter's more for adults I mean
you do get kids on on Twitter like
there's a lot of Kpop fans on Twitter
and stuff and you know Twitter can be
quite a toxic place so it's not really
the best place for a kids yeah with all
the views expressed on there um so yeah
it's mostly Tick Tock I mean Tick Tock
is very fast you've got the 15 second
videos people constantly scroll through
and I spend hours sometimes you know at
night just lying a bit of scrolling
through and you just can't turn it off
and there are some people that describe
it as a digital fentanyl because it gets
you hooked you know from first use
you're hooked and then you're constantly
on it all day and and uh you know
whatever videos they're seeing you know
it's not right for a kid to be on the
phone all day when they should be doing
other things they should be at school
they should be doing their homework um
so uh Tick Tock is the main platform
they're using and again the risk is
um certain views can be promoted on
there
um which which is you know what kids are
being exposed to and um Tick Tock can be
a fun place there's lots of Dance videos
there's lots of cute videos but there
are videos that kids might see that
aren't meant for kids
um and Tick Tock I will give them credit
they do a lot of things that they don't
show alcohol they don't show cigarettes
there's certain things you can't show so
I will give them credit for they do
protect children and I believe you have
to be 13 to be on the app so they do
take some kind of responsibility with
that but you know a kid's a kid if they
want to go on something they'll find a
way like a VPN or something no I
completely agree and you said something
just earlier on in in that point which I
found quite shocking the TR all the
trans kids are cool kids now yeah so in
um like in particularly in America in
schools uh being trans or non-binary is
considered cool and trendy and if you're
not in one of these groups you're not
cool so like if you're a male or a
female you're not cool anymore you're
kind of so like last year so it's like
it has become a trend in some schools
where you know if you're not part of
trans or non-binary group you are then
an outcast and you know you feel left
out and I feel that's one of the reasons
why kids are feeling the pressure to you
know be non-gender conforming you know
have different pronouns or whatever just
to try and fit in with their friends
because this has been a complete about
term because when I went to school I
mean it was not that long ago I'm sure
people will say that it is but you know
the worst thing you could be was to
stand out in any way
particularly if you were gay or bisexual
the abuse that you got was horrific and
now to see it completely go the other
ways it's it's shocking in a way well
yeah I'm obviously you know I'm happy I
support all people so I'm happy that
um people that identify their voice can
be accepted now I'm really glad to hear
that and you know 40 years ago it was
very hard for a trans person to be trans
so I'm glad they're able to live how
they want now but the the issue is you
know like you said years ago it was not
as common and there were generally
people that were trans and they would
have to go for a lot of hardships to get
where they are but now there's no checks
and balances now it's easy you can just
self-identify and go into a woman's
toilet you know and there are cases
where men just put on a dress they go in
the women's toilet and assault happens
there was in Virginia and America and
Loughton County a boy wearing a skirt
went into the women's bathroom raped a
girl and you know there was no justice
um so there are real issues with that
but it's also important to be sensitive
you know we have to understand these
kids are going through you know their
teen years they might have identity
struggles they might have issues but you
know it has become a trend and that's
the issue you know we should support all
people but you know kids shouldn't be
you know forced or pressurized to do
this from kindergarten we've explored
this issue with a lot of people and
there's a there's a range of opinions
and I I can see that your approach uh
understandably is to to have compassion
for people who who uh feel that you know
they need to transitional they have
gender dysphoria and all sorts of things
and I totally get that but on the other
hand some people would say well I mean
the question I want to ask you I suppose
is this do you think it's possible to
change your sex or do you think it's
possible to change your ethnicity in the
way that you attempted to do well you
know when I announced I was Korean I
thought you know one of the reasons I
thought that was okay was because people
are changing their gender all the time
sure so what's the difference between
changing your gender or saying that I'm
from Korea yeah no on the contrary what
I was doing was kind of almost made more
sense you know I love this country I've
lived in this country I identify as that
culture it's almost made more sense so
you know I again I'm compassionate I
accept people want to live certain ways
and and that's fine but um also we have
to look at you know there is biology
it's just science you know there are if
you're born a certain way you know some
people change over time but I think a
lot of that's a societal pressure you
know it's from a young age that sorry
what I'm getting at it okay and you
mentioned biology if you did no matter
how many surges you did if you did a DNA
test none of them would show you up to
have Korean ethnicity right and likewise
with sex it would be the same process so
and and this is where a lot of the
feminists you mentioned women who are
concerned about this year their argument
would be that yes have compassion for
people just with gender dysphoria or
body image issues or whatever it is that
people are going through and get them
the psychological help that they need
but there will be very few people
actually particularly if it's become a
trend as you say who who are genuinely
in need of transition a lot of it is
confused young people and if we pretend
as you said yourself as a society that
you can change your sex or your gender
or whatever you can change your
ethnicity then of course children and
sometimes adults will look at that and
go as you did well if you can change it
why can't you change do you know what I
mean so do you believe that it's
possible to change your sex or it's
possible to change your ethnicity with
surgery and Trauma I mean I don't
believe it's possible to change biology
you know I think it's kind of what I did
I just had plastic surgery to look
Korean yeah it's exactly the same you're
having plastic surgery to look like a
woman yeah you're having plastic just
look like a man it doesn't change what's
underneath it doesn't change the way
you're born so again if they took a you
know a gender test it would show their
biological gender if I took a test to
show us you know British so you know
there's there's no real difference there
and um you know again people want to
look a certain way that's fine they want
to live aside to my that's fine but
don't impose on other people because
that's the issue and there are again
generally people that are trans out
there but their voices are silenced by
these kind of people these trans
activists that have hijacked their
movement and it's actually made it
harder for them to be trans you know
because they're getting hate online and
stuff because people these trans
activists have caused so many problems
for women of course so many problems for
kids and it's it's very offensive to
women what some of these activists are
doing you know they're trying to silence
the word women uh Cambridge Dictionary
just updated their official definition
of man and woman yesterday and it's no
longer says that it's the biology you're
born with so I know you can't change the
biology you can't change your gender but
you can look a certain way you can feel
a certain way and you can live your life
that way which again is what I was doing
I had plastic surgery to be Korean
someone will have plastic surgery like a
woman what's the difference Ollie
we there's a balance that needs to be
struck between
the the rights of the individual
and also as well realizing that this is
a mental illness absolutely because and
look I read online correct me if this is
wrong you said that you wanted to cut or
take a uh reduce the size of your penis
yeah because uh in Korea they have
smaller size penises it is that true or
is that just nonsense that was actually
it was misquoted so basically I was I
was going to transition so I had the
facial feminization so I was gonna
actually cut it off so I was going to go
to Thailand and cut it off
um you know to look like a Korean woman
so you know it was misquotes that did
some interview in Newsweek and they
misquoted it so they said I wanted to
cut a little bit off I wanted to cut it
off completely to transition to become a
woman so that was um the kind of issue
and is that one of the points where you
went uh okay maybe this is starting to
get yeah I was thinking you know that's
something I could could regret yeah
I might miss that one it might be a bit
of a weird adjustment so yeah yeah that
was again because I was is suffering
from gender dysphoria and again it is
mental it's a mental health issue you
know plain and simple it's like people
need love and compassion but we need to
address it as a mental health issue not
as you know a transition or whatever
where you know kids want to do this you
should support them if you dare question
it you're a bad person you know why
can't we question this happening you
know why can't we question the erosion
of women's rights uh for this very very
small minority which is like 0.3 of the
population you see I completely agree
with you and to me we're not really
striking that balance where we we're
talking about people's feelings and of
course people's feelings are important
Ollie I'm not discounting that but when
it comes to people literally chopping
bits off themselves changing their
bodies
living on medication for the rest of
their life and in some cases shortening
their lifespans making themselves in
fertile and making themselves infertile
at what point do we go do we step in and
go
I don't think this is a good way of
living or a good choice do you see what
I mean I absolutely I fully support like
I think in America we need in all 50
States legislation to stop gender
affirming care and teens because
currently you have in places like Oregon
and Los Angeles you have 12 13 years
olds they're going for these surgeries
the doctors are making it so easy and
they get seventy thousand dollars per
surgery for the full body by the way so
there's a lot of money involved um so
you know we need to we need to have laws
to protect these kids you know if
somebody you know we should be giving
people psychologist appointments years
and years ago if someone was generally
trans they would spend you know four or
five years going to doctor's
appointments having psychology
appointments to make sure that that's
really what they wanted now it's as easy
as you know one two three you go into
the doctor they say what would you like
to be today boy or a girl and you know
they give them a prescription they chop
everything off and it's like that you
know we we need some kind of legislation
in place you know it's who cares about
people's feelings when there are people
kids that are being you know mutilated
in my mind it's no different to female
genital mutilation that you have In some
cultures in Somalia what's the
difference between that and cutting a
child up in America that's 13 you know
all under the kind of trans umbrella
yeah and
you were a child of that age and you had
grown up in this time with access to
tick tock and Instagram and all the rest
of it do you think that that would have
been your path oh my God I mean I can't
imagine I mean it's bad enough of me now
I've obviously being Korean and being
trans I can't imagine I can't imagine
what I would have been you know probably
being an alien or something
um so yeah I think it's now it's like
it's so difficult for kids now you know
but kids shouldn't be learning these
things it's it's fine to learn about
love and acceptance of different people
like LGBT that's a very good thing but
you know we shouldn't be some schools in
America there was this uh case recently
this University Dean was teaching 14
year olds how to use dildos and butt
plugs like sick really really sick stuff
I had like our lgbtq plus Health Center
come in they were passing around butt
plugs and dildos to my students talking
about queer sex using blue versus using
spit meet Joe Bruno dean of students at
the prestigious branches W Parker
private school in Chicago which happens
to charge forty thousand dollars per
student they're just like passing around
dildos butt plugs the kids are just
playing with them they're like how do
you how does this book work how do I do
like how does this work that's a really
like a little part of my job parents
might be stunned to learn that Bruno's
version of love and acceptance means
handing out sex toys to underage
students that's so amazing and
everybody's cool with that like they're
about plugs and the dildos nobody
complaints I mean if the parents found
out what they you know queer sex this is
the drag queen that came in what's her
name uh Alexis bevels Alexis bevels and
just hung out in my classroom and was
there girl hung out in my office you
have so much freedom and so much
wiggle room
so much money I mean [ __ ] losing
stuff these are okay with that too
they don't know
they would it's like we I wouldn't even
like run it by them like why would I run
it by them they'd be like oh my God
that's wonderful like how old would the
kids at with the classroom for team a
team
and funnily enough the university issued
a statement and they actually sided with
him as opposed to the kids so they're
actually abusing these kids they're
teaching these kids things so there are
certain things that kids need to be
protected from you know that is just
beyond shocking you know again with the
Balenciaga Scandal when they had kids
holding bondage Bears how are we
allowing this thankfully everybody's
speaking up but how has this become so
normal that the person that speaks out
is canceled the kids aren't protected
the kids are the victims they're
constantly victimized the schools
protect the people teaching these things
to kids and it's it's not right so we
need something in place to stop these
things um Florida is a great example
um with Governor DeSantis they actually
passed the bill to kind of protect kids
from being taught
um certain things such as you know
transitioning and stuff from a young age
and that was you know dubbed the don't
say gay bill but really it's nothing to
do with that it was you know Ron
DeSantis supports the LGBT community
Florida supports clgbt Community but
that was more of an issue of
indoctrinating kids they don't want
certain things be taught in kindergarten
you know which I think is a good thing
we should have more legislation and laws
like that but sadly when you try to pass
laws like that it's suddenly you're
homophobic you're transphobic but that's
not the issue most people aren't
homophobic most people just want the
best for kids most people want to
protect kids you know if someone's kid
is gay or lesbian most parents would
support that these days which is which
is fantastic but you know what people
don't support is kids being taught these
things in school like how to use a dildo
at age 14 like these really shocking
things you know that should be kept out
of the classroom well you bring up an
issue that I think is one of the biggest
and it's almost like an underwater
hidden concern of people because until
recently you weren't allowed to talk
about it in in many social media
platforms like Twitter you and I were
talking in the car on the way here about
the fact that you can now
use the word groomer online for example
and I know that for a lot of people part
of the concern is that this has all
become very muddled we've kind of slept
walk our way through let's not beat up
gay people in the street which I think
we'd all agree was a bad thing and
definitely shouldn't happen and people
should be treated equally no matter who
they love and all of that which again
we'd all agree with two like your
children should if your child says
they're trans that means they're trans
and if you if you question that you're
transphobic through to as you say
children being taught all sorts of
sexualized stuff that's not really about
lgbtq at all and it seems to be about
something else in Thailand you you
mentioned this teacher but we didn't we
have this was it the family sex show in
the history yeah we had the family
section I don't know did you follow this
with the Trans person with the piano
there was a family sex show that was in
Bristol in which at some point all of
the actors were encouraged to remove
their clothes to the level of nudity
that they felt comfortable with uh and
the audience range I think it was
starting from five or seven years old
something like that uh and the lyrics
were I have a penis in my pants touch it
touch it touch it touch it and I think
when people see that kind of stuff and
combined with the stuff that you're
talking about and also you know I don't
know if you saw Matt Walsh's documentary
yeah if you look into the history of how
some of these ideas came about they were
pushed by outright pedophiles right
absolutely so you put all that together
do you think there is an element
obviously not all trans people not even
all trans activists but do you think
there's an element of this which is
about early sexualization of children I
mean absolutely I mean you look at
anything in the media in Hollywood
movies in fashion like with Balenciaga
everything is about sexualization these
days and the thing is these people like
these trans radical trans activists they
have actually hijacked the LGBT movement
there's a lot of LGBT people that don't
want to be associated with these people
they've really taken that movement and
you know if anyone dares call someone a
groomer you are transphobic you're
homophobic that's not correct people are
just calling out what they see which is
grooming so when you have a fashion
brand trying to normalize the sexual
exploitation of kids you know glorifying
it I mean Balenciaga they had a supreme
court document which was trying to you
know pass a law to say that digital
child porn was okay you know and that's
become so normal we see it every day in
movies even in cartoons uh in school you
have drag shows in America again people
always say oh you're homophobic to try
and stop these drag story hours all
these drag shows but really no kids
should be going to a drag show where the
dragster drag queen or the artist is
stripping performing twerking and you
know I've seen videos in Florida there
was a bar where a drag queen was
twerking holding like a three-year-old
girl's hand and they're basically naked
basically naked and Florida uh moved to
revoke the place's liquor license if
they did not stop those drag shows and I
believe they've stopped now but you know
again it's it's classed as oh if you
dare speak out against screaming you're
homophobic and it's not the case at all
it's literally there's so much
exploitation out there right now and
there are people trying to normalize
these things like calling Predators
minor attractive persons you know the
language that even the Washington Post
New York Times you know these kind of
woke newspapers there was Washington
Post recently they did an article
praising this play that was about
pedophiles and they were saying you know
maybe this is a good thing so they're
it's like they're trying to push this
agenda you know that it's okay to
exploit children when it's never been
okay in history and it never will be
okay I mean it's I completely agree with
you I will say that there is nothing new
I remember Charlotte Church the singer I
can't remember what newspaper it was or
magazine did a countdown until when she
was legal wow
not surprising you know and so you know
if you look back and rock and roll Chuck
Berry's sweet little 16 you know they've
always been those elements those people
in in our culture who have been trying
to do this and thankfully we now have
stopped that element of it which is very
worrying that there's another another
element creeping into our society well I
don't remember being taught about bug
plugs and stuff
it wasn't it wasn't a thing about them
but it's they've become very more Brazen
now you know they're very open they you
know they don't even want to hide
anymore these people I mean if we look
at what happened with Jeffrey Epstein's
Island if you look at the flight logs
how many Hollywood celebrities and
powerful people were there it's very
very shocking and you know people that
are you know loved by millions of people
they see this and you know what were
they doing on the island so it's really
they don't for legal purposes having a
very nice time exactly of course
enjoying the trumpets you know why have
these people become so open they don't
want to hide it I mean again their best
example is the Balenciaga thing recently
where they really didn't want to hide
what their agenda was no they had all of
these horrific signs about child abuse
their stylists had images of you know
child abuse on their Instagram
absolutely shocking torture the artists
they were taking inspiration from were
doing you know pictures of children
being tortured and amputated
um and it's just like deep but um you
know they don't hide in the shadows
anymore they're more open because they
feel that over time and time years and
years they can normalize this and the
you know if you look at examples in the
past when a certain type of people want
to normalize something you don't do it
straight away because people reject that
they do it slowly over time they put it
in the pop culture they put in the
magazines the fashion shows until slowly
it becomes normalized that oh it's just
another child holding a bondage bear oh
it's just another child with a a a trans
drag queen naked oh that's normal we see
that all the time in music videos I
don't have a problem with that because I
see it all the time so that's the issue
is they've become so brave and they've
pushed it for years and years and years
and it's almost becoming normalized do
you have a website or do you plan to
have a website because if you do then
easy DNS is a company for you easy DNS
is the perfect domain name registrar
provider and web host for you they have
a track record of standing up for their
clients whether it be canceled culture D
platform attacks or overzealous
government agencies he knows about that
so will you in a second easy DNS have
Rock Solid Network infrastructure and
fantastic customer support they're in
your corner no matter what the world
throws at you unless it's your
ex-girlfriend in which case you're on
your own you know about that move your
domains and websites over to easy DNS
right now all you've got to do is go to
easydns.com forward slash triggered
that's easydns.com forward slash
triggered use our promo code which is
also triggered and get 50 off the
initial purchase sign up for their
newsletter access of easy which tells
you everything you need to know about
technology privacy and censorship
and Ollie you mentioned this um Dylan
Mulvaney
who's been to the White House yeah and
this is a person who's again an online
influencer uh on Tick Tock yeah I'm
feeling my age as I'm talking here this
is a trans person on Tick Tock who
promotes being trans basically is that
fair to say yeah but they do more of a
caricature so um they actually started
out as an actor and a comedian and they
saw they were getting a lot of views
this is my belief and a lot of people
hold this belief they started out as a
caricature mocking women you know
holding up tampons and joking about I
can't wait to use these basically just
stereotyping women you know like high
heels the blonde hair I'm such you know
I did see blonde basically just mocking
women and they're subtle out like that
and you know the trans Lobby will always
say oh you should never question someone
that identifies as trans yeah they were
questioning me he wasn't they kept keep
saying oh he wasn't really transsexual
like I was wearing dress as I was doing
the makeup I had the facial feminization
I had the extensions I was doing a lot
more than Dylan Morgan Dylan morgany has
grown their hair and had laser hair
removal that's it you know which you
know if if she generally feels that way
okay whatever but you know why are
people saying that I wasn't trans yeah
Dylan's done literally nothing Ollie can
I interrupt you because this is this
goes into and believe me I've been on
the other end of this question I'm about
to ask you because when we have someone
who's very strong uh and clear on this
issue like Posey Parker who we've had on
the show right she's like why do you
keep calling this person she it's a he
yeah right so is it if if I if I get
longer hair and I mean if I got hair
like I can't afford all the hair removal
that it would take for me to not have
body hair but if I did all that yeah
right would I become a she am I a she
you'd still be the way you're born
biologically so this Dylan person surely
they they must be a heathen by that
definition yeah they are they are yeah
they just want to identify as well women
and you know they identify that way okay
but what they're doing is they're
actually mocking women and they're
parroting women and do you think there's
a danger as well because if people as
you again coming back I'm just re
rehashing what you've already said if
you would watch stuff like that and it
influences you and influences people it
makes you go well if you can do this why
can't I do this other thing do do you
think that someone like that is actually
doing damage to to other people
absolutely I mean it's harmful to when
you have a platform to do that and again
that's why I do regrets in the past my
behaviors because I feel like maybe I
was influencing people in the wrong way
so I like I have a deep deep regret
about that and that's why I'm going to
church I'm trying to redeem myself and
trying to move on and trying to help
people now so you know people that have
a platform any platform whether it's TV
movies you have a moral responsibility
to send a good message to the world you
know
um so I feel it's very harmful for
people like Dylan to portray these
stereotypes to mock women and you know
when kid sees de la mulvani with the
present United States you know that
means wow maybe I can do that I just
need to grow my hair and identify as a
woman I can meet you know Biden because
you know Biden seems to be inviting all
sorts of people at the moment um you
won't have an interview of a real
journalist but he'll invite all these
people he just had a drag queen at the
White House who just tweeted that kids
can suck their dick you know what yes a
drag queen that was at the white house
uh recently uh Biden invited loads of
drag queens to do with the the marriage
equality acts being passed um this drag
queen tweeted very recently about kids
can suck my dick on Twitter basically
all the conservatives were calling them
out for being there and then they
responded by saying oh kids can suck my
dick and I'm thinking this is the this
you know when these people are going to
the White House what message does that
show to their followers that oh if I say
that if I do that I can get an invite to
the White House wow this is so cool you
know and kids are very impressionable
they fall victim to this they want to
emulate people like Dylan malvernay and
they think you know oh this is fun you
know Dylan's making millions of dollars
now mocking women you know she's got a
he's got to deal with Tampax and you
know maybe I can be like that you know
he's got to deal with temperatures
exactly I guess up his nose I don't know
but um yeah so he's got to deal with
Tampax and Tampax had backlash for that
because they're getting trans people to
promote their products which is you know
it's obviously they want some attention
the brand you know it's a controversial
marketing tactic but um end of the day
it's a joke because they're going to
lose all their customers all their
customers are women that actually
menstruate and actually have periods
people like Dylan malverny will never
experience that they'll never go through
the suffering a woman has to go through
so it's deeply offensive for 10 packs to
do something like that you know if I was
a woman I wouldn't buy Tampax anymore
based on them openly mocking women how
big a problem is it and to an extent
this is a challenge that we face which
is audience capture you are an
influencer you're online you've got a
huge you know you've got a huge audience
you make your living from being online
you put out content
there's some content that really flies
and you think to yourself
well I'll just do more of that content
right and before you know where you are
you've gone down a particular route or
Rabbit Hole pathway and all of a sudden
you're not where you were what you
wanted to be I mean yeah I mean I kind
of fall for that as well because I think
you know most people on social media it
is an addiction people get very addicted
and they fall into it so people like
Dylan again started out acting you know
they were in Broadway in the Book of
Mormon show started acting they were
desperate to be famous and then they
realized you know suddenly they put on
the wig or whatever and they were
getting loads of views loads of
interactions and you know when you come
out as trans or whatever you called
stunning and brave you get all of this
appraisal which I also got when I
announced I was trans I got so many all
these people that were hating on me
suddenly were like oh we love you we
accept you I'm thinking how ironic you
wouldn't accept me when I was Korean but
now suddenly you accept me for you know
becoming a woman or whatever so
um it's it's just it's crazy and what is
it like to go through that Journey where
people were openly mocking you you were
you were this figure of fun you then and
when you were a viral sensation to then
transitioning where people were saying
you know this is stunning and brave and
blah blah blah and then to go as and
then to take the third part of your
journey which is to go I've made a
mistake well you know I think it's the
best thing to do when you regret
something in life is just to accept it
and admit it and you know I have
apologized for past behaviors you know
but also you know people they get so
carried away online you know I do K-pop
music people take offense to me singing
Korean songs doing fun music videos to
entertain and make people laugh and they
get really caught up in it I'm thinking
just enjoy the music video have a laugh
I'm trying to make people smile you know
when kovid was happening I was making so
many tick tocks to make people smile you
know because we all need more happiness
in the world I'm trying to always
project positivity to the world so when
I was having people canceling me oh
you're racist you're doing this I'm not
I generally feel this way I felt Korean
at the time but I just want to make
people happy is there anything wrong
with that no and but what does it mean
to feel Korean Ollie well you know I
think a lot of foreigners that live in
Korea do feel that way it's just you are
endeared with that particular culture
you love that particular place you feel
at home with those people so I just felt
like I fitted him with that particular
group of people that particular culture
and you know I have apologized for my
extreme Obsession in the past but at the
end of the day there's no real harm in
that you know if people assimilate into
a certain culture you know let's say you
lived in Japan for 10 years you'd feel a
part of that culture right you'd feel a
part of that societal group you'd
probably yeah but you'd never be
Japanese though I'm not having a go at
you because yeah like I said I have a
tremendous amount of respect for you
being able to come out and go you know I
made these mistakes I regret them I'm on
a different path and this is the only
thing human beings have when we make
mistakes as we all do and some of our
mistakes are more extreme than others
and some some people go further than
others so this this isn't in any way
having to go at you yeah but I would say
that you know you know how you were
saying well if I can be a woman why
can't I be Korean I suppose the reason
it is in my opinion still quite
dangerous to pretend that somebody can
be Korean like look I was born in Russia
yeah right I came to this country I I'm
a British national but I would never say
that I'm English correct
it sounds good in his accent correct
yeah
but do you see what I'm saying right so
um the reason I bring this up and the
reason I do think it's actually uh
harmful is if you say well why can't I
be Korean fair enough let's say fair
enough for the sake of argument someone
else go well if I can be Korean why
can't I be a different age or a
different sex and it's a never-ending
cycle of essentially lies right we are
lying to ourselves because the truth is
when you know I I am someone who came to
this country from another country and
you came to Korea from another country
so we're quite similar in that way but
no matter how much surgery I do I don't
think I'm ever going to be English right
right and likewise I don't think you
could be like someone who's in love with
Korean culture and fully embedded in a
foreigner who's really made themselves
part of that that world and I think
that's something Koreans probably really
like uh Foreigner coming in really
respect in that culture but I think we
should also not pretend and if you don't
mind me saying that you actually are
able to become a different ethnicity
because it's not true would you agree
you know I've got to that point now
where I've accepted who I am I've
accepted my identity and I've kind of
moved on from that past Obsession I had
um but again I was going on what I'd
been taught that you know if you can
have 500 pronouns I'm just going to be
Korean why not you know I just thought
why not that's why I'm saying and it's
maybe not I've realized now that you
know that was not healthy and it was not
natural and you can't just suddenly do
that because again you said people like
can identify as a different age and
that's a very dangerous thing so but
again when you have the culture that
says you can be trans you can change
gender no I just thought why not you
know I love this country no no I'm not
having to go yeah for the past yeah if
you were talking now as if yeah and this
is why I think if you don't mind me
saying yeah I think it's your
responsibility now to kind of go well
you can't change your ethnicity yeah
I've realized that now you know what I'm
saying at the time obviously because I
was struggling yeah yeah no I get it
yeah but I think now you yeah look
you're allowed to do what you want to do
I'm just saying from a from my
perspective as I sit here talking to you
I think you it's actually would be a
good thing for you to go you can't
change your ethnicity no matter how much
surgery you do from a response I mean
I'm trying to be more responsible now
I'm trying to speak out on things and
you know that like you said I agree with
what you're saying and I do take
responsibility for my past actions and
I'm trying to learn from that and grow
and that's in the spirit which I offer
that bit which is yeah I I know that you
you're in a totally different Journey
which is why you're here which is why I
said I have a lot of respect yeah I just
think you have to have Clarity with
people listening and watching yeah about
like you went through what you went
through and you did it for reasons the
team correct you at the time but I think
this is where someone like Posey Parker
has changed my mind quite a bit where
it's like you've got to be honest yeah
you've got to be true to the to to and
go to wherever that Honesty he takes you
and I think in your case from my
perspective it takes you to you can't
change your sex and you can't change
your ethnicity even though I thought I
could and I did it right and I did think
I could at the time because again
everyone else can do whatever they want
so I think we need to more challenge
what's going on in society now and you
know stop all this craziness you know
stop all this self-identification of men
going into women's toilets and just you
know just try and accept who we are the
way we're born that's what the focus
should be now so that's the message I
want to project is you know just be
happy the way you're born and you know I
get some people will still be unhappy
they still want to do surgeries but you
know maybe don't do anything crazy like
I did maybe don't go to the extreme and
just try and learn to love yourself
because at the end of the day it doesn't
matter what we look like on the outside
it's what's inside that really matters
Ollie um when I listen to your journey
and when we're talking it seems to me
that what this is all about really is
acceptance you just wanted to be
accepted right was was that really at
the heart of all of this yeah that's
that's really why you know I've never
felt accepted in society I always felt
very different and ostracized um so
that's why again when I was in Korea
that was the first time in my life where
I actually felt accepted and loved and
you know welcomed and I never felt like
that before so why is that why was that
early I don't know I guess because I was
always different to other people like I
was always very kind of at school I was
always very quiet again because I was
bullied and stuff was very quiet I was
very unique and weird to some people you
know I didn't fit in with the trending
people or the cool kids at school and
stuff so I just never fitted in I was
always a bit of an outcast I was always
a different thinker so I feel that's why
I felt kind of you know that it wasn't
accepted so that's why I thought you
know becoming Korean or whatever having
the surgery would make me feel accepted
and actually had the opposite effect I
started getting you know horrible hate
online and stuff and um you know I just
I've never wanted to be hated I just
want people to accept me for who I am
and thankfully I've accepted myself now
which is part of the journey and I hope
other people can accept you know the
real me that's I've finally found well
uh it's been great having you on on that
happy note we've got as you know a
couple of questions that for our local
supporters but as always we've got one
final question which we ask all our
guests which is what is the one thing
we're not talking about as a society
that you think we should be
um I mean we we've touched on these
subjects today but again child
exploitation because there are a lot of
people that either turn a blind eye or
don't see what's really going on so I
think we need as a society collectively
everybody to speak up you know it
shouldn't be a conservative or democrat
issue it should be everyone you know
speaking up for the protection of
children so we can't allow this constant
indoctrination with fashion brands with
Hollywood movies with you know the
mainstream media allowing this narrative
so we all need to speak up and protect
kids and you know and call out these
things like you said on Twitter the word
grooming is being used again and you
know rightly so we should be able to
call out these people and um you know
protect kids that should be the number
one priority and I think everyone can
get behind that most people yeah yeah
yeah not Balenciaga
um and before we go to our locals
questions if people want to find you
online Ollie where is the best place to
do them so Twitter is Ollie London TV
Instagrams London Ollie Tick Tock at
Ollie London
um
YouTube channel YouTube Ollie London so
yeah it's kind of mostly early London
all right thanks so much for coming on
thank you very much thank you guys for
watching and listening we will see you
very soon with another brilliant episode
like this one or raw show all of them go
out at 7 p.m UK time and for those of
you who like your trigonometry on the go
it's also available as a podcast take
care and see you soon guys
whether any medical professionals along
the way who suggested you shouldn't get
these surgeries who explicitly said to
don't do this
[Music]
foreign